ça ce sont mes notes sur la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui maintenant si vous n'avez
pas envie de vous endetter à lire ce
truc je vais vous expliquer nous a
vraiment de quoi on parle aujourd'hui on
parle de l'iphone 10r troisième modèle
de cette année modèle low cost de chez
apple
en tout cas c'est pas vraiment un modèle
low cost c'est le successeur de l'iphone
8 plus un design qui était forcément
revues repensé pour être dans les
standards actuels d'iphone 10r qui à la
fois très proche et très différent de
l'iphone 10 aces et encore plus du lycée
ce match quoique pas si différent donc
la question à se poser c'est est-ce que
cet iphone 10 r est le meilleur rapport
qualité prix
est-ce qu'il faut acheter cet iphone dit
c'est pourquoi il faut l'acheter quels
sont les points positifs les points
négatifs
comment ils se situent par rapport à
l'iphone 10 aces et au final est-ce que
cet iphone qui servent aux le courir ou
non donc c'est ce qu'on regarde
aujourd'hui dans cette vidéo
[Musique]
parce que ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
que cet iphone 10 rc qu'il est quand
même 300 euros moins cher que l'iphone
10 aces et qui est 400 euros moins cher
que l'iphone 17 max donc pour cours
à ce prix là est ce que ça vaut le coup
de se prendre un iphone 10 r oui non
parce qu'on est quand même sur un
smartphone coûte la modique somme de 855
euros 1,28 parce qu'il faut bien définir
les choses l'iphone 10 r est un
smartphone haut de gamme l'iphone 10 s
est un smartphone très haut de gamme
le fleuron d'apple et l'iphone 10 s max
sensiblement le même avec un plus grand
écran maintenant quels sont les atouts
quels sont les inconvénients de cet
iphone 10r premier gros point positif de
ce smartphone et son grand écran de 6,1
pouces liquid retina c'est donc un écran
lcd
ça c'est un très très très très gros
points de différence entre l'iphone 10
aces et l'iphone 10 r il faut pas se
tromper
là dessus on a un smartphone avec un
écran plus grand par contre on est un
smartphone avec des bords qui sont plus
grands que ceux de l'iphone 10 aces
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire au
final ça veut dire que en termes d'image
globale entame en tout cas de zones
utilisées par l'écran on est
sensiblement sur la même chose que
l'iphone 10s c'est-à-dire 5,8 pouces
alors ce n'est pas un écran 5 pouces et
d'un écran de 6 pouces mais comme les
bords sont un peu plus grands on a un
peu la même sensation que sur l'iphone
10s néanmoins je trouve que la qualité
de l'écran est vraiment la csq a appelé
apple c'est le liquid retina alors le
liquid retina c'est ni plus ni moins que
le nom commercial de l'écran lcd d'apple
il ya eu par contre un vrai bon boulot
de fait là dessus avec un écran qui est
vraiment bien étalonné j'ai passé un
paquet d'heures à regarder des vidéos
sur youtube et je trouve que la qualité
de l'écran est vraiment vraiment
vraiment bien fait et même vraiment
bluffant le fait qu'on soit sur un écran
lcd on ne sent pas une énorme différence
alors effectivement c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose on va pas avoir les
mêmes contrastes on ne va pas avoir la
même qualité
on va par un côté un peu brillant de
l'écran oled mais par contre vraiment ça
ne me gêne absolument pas et je ne suis
pas sur quel usage vous sentiez vraiment
une énorme différence pour moi il ya un
énorme boulot qui était fait par apple
sur la qualité de l'écran donc là dessus
même si c'est un écran lcd on n'est pas
sur n'importe quel écran lcd sur marché
vous
avait plein d'écrans lcd de différentes
qualités certains sont bien
certains sont carrément très mauvais
celui là par contre est vraiment aux
piscines ça pourrait d'ailleurs une des
références dans le monde de l'écran lcd
il dit ça en toute sincérité deuxième
chose que j'aime vraiment sur cet iphone
10 r c'est sa caméra arrière vous avez
la même caméra que sur l'iphone 10 aces
et 17 max à savoir 12 mégapixels grand
angle avec une ouverture de f 1.8 donc
vraiment très très bon en faible
luminosité la qualité photo la qualité
vidéo de l'iphone 10r est vraiment
excellent il ya aucun compromis qui
était fait par apple d'astuces ont
vraiment mis le paquet pour qu'on trouve
vraiment la même qualité
les mêmes exigences et pas du tout avoir
une caméra au rabais sur ce modèle et
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment des très très
gros points tantôt smartphone c'est le
fait de se dire on ne fait absolument
rien au rabé on propose un écran lcd
bien excellente écran lcd
on propose un seul module photo à rien
alors effectivement je sais qu'on ne
pourra pas faire que vous pourrez faire
un téléphone 10s à 90 s max est plutôt
normal d'ailleurs parce que on a quand
même un écart de prix donc on peut pas
tout avoir à ce prix là par contre
l'appareil photo que vous avez il est
sans compromis le capteur 12 mégapixels
est vraiment excellent en faible
luminosité
ça marche très très bien et en plus
c'est un super boulot qui fait derrière
du point de vue logiciel mais sans m'en
parler juste après pour l'instant tout
de suite on va aller faire quelques
photos
qualité et pour voir qu'on n'a pas
double objectif photo le mode portrait
et la dent mode portrait complètement
logiciel n'est par contre il ya un vrai
bon boulot tu fais dessus et en plus ce
qui est vraiment cool c'est comme ça
avec un indice s vous pouvez
complètement moduler la profondeur de
champ en post prod la up quasiment pas
de profondeur là beaucoup de profondeur
ça marche extrêmement bien et ça c'est
aussi super cool entre pâques et coup
vous avez différents modes d'éclairage
du studio qui existent dessus vous
pouvez venir paramétrer sa marche
extrêmement bien et ça aussi c'est super
chouette entre pas qui est vraiment
excellent sans cet iphone du sien en
tout cas pas sur celui là spécifiquement
mais surtout les iphone 10 r c'est le
retour de la couleur en grand pompe
là vous est pris aux modèles à led il en
existe plein d'autres qui sont tout
aussi jolis les uns que les autres pour
avoir un smartphone avec plus de peps
plus de tonus vous pouvez y aller
franchement c'est assez incroyable
autre point qui est vraiment très très
très bien sur cet iphone 10 r c'est la
présence de la caméra contexte la
présence de feuilles c'est dit 'face à
guidon d'un smartphone pas moins 900
euros c'est aussi très cool parce que
forcément fait saïdi d'un kader et rodez
c'est une techno qui est récente c'est
une techno qui compte cher et qu'on ne
retrouve pas dans tous les smartphones
et c'est vraiment bien qu'on puisse la
voir sur un smartphone apple tout neuf à
moins de 900 euros
parce que il ya un truc à savoir aussi
en termes de stratégie c'est le fait
d'avoir fait disparaître les fautes 10
de l'année dernière il ya vraiment un
but en terme de positionnement tarifaire
déjà dans un premier temps il faut
savoir qu'apple a dit l'iphone dit c'est
l'iphone dès 10 ans l'iphone
anniversaire donc ils avaient juste pour
but d'être là présent sur ronan pour
marquer les 10 ans de l'iphone et de
dégager est ensuite arrivé sans
successeur les fautes 10 16 17 max et ce
qui arrivera dans les années suivantes
mais aussi une vraie logique en termes
de positionnement tarifaire parce que
vous voyez très bien que tous les
nouveaux iphone maintenant nous devons
avoir cette fameuse petite encoche quel
aurait été l'intérêt pour apple d'avoir
un iphone 10 aces à 1100 et quelques
euros à bord un expédient sert à 855
euros et un iphone dit qu'on aurait mis
à quel tarif 950 euros
il ya un peu tu vas pas été logique donc
du coup il a dégagé on a un smartphone
l'iphone 10r qui est un excellent
smartphone avec faith heidi qui trouve
très facilement sa place au catalogue
d'apple
et ça aussi c'est très très mal un autre
point qui est vraiment excellent là
dessus c'est la performance avec la puce
à 12
bionic de cette année voyons un score
surtout benchmark 313 1466
c'est juste énorme ça c'est aussi un
compromis qui n'a pas été fait par apple
le fait de se dire vous avez
effectivement un smartphone moins cher
mais par contre on a le meilleur de ce
qu'on sait faire à l'intérieur on a le
meilleur sort vous avez la puce à 12
bionique les puces avec le nord à lille
jeunes avec une intelligence
artificielle qui va vraiment devenir
optimisée et déjà la performance vous
donner un regain de puissance quand vous
en avez besoin et le reste du temps
faire attention à l'autonomie pas
consommer trop et ça c'est un point qui
est vraiment vraiment vraiment excellent
c'est vraiment cool qu'apple ait mis une
puce à 12 bionique là dedans plutôt
qu'une puce à eauze donc on est une
machine plus performante que l'iphone
dit de l'année dernière table de
performances en termes de jeu j'ai fait
aussi bien de la réalité augmentée
j'étais déjà fait du pib chez schaeffer
dufour night j'ai fait pas mal de choses
là dessus ça fonctionne c'est vraiment
bon et je trouve vraiment que cette
machine a pas du tout à rougir en termes
de performance par rapport avec les
10-16 de cette année en plus de ça et là
où c'est vraiment génial on va donc
avoir une meilleure autonomie sur iphone
10r que sur l'iphone 10 cesse c'est à
dire un smartphone qui coûte 300 euros
moins cher que tu auras une bien
meilleure autonomie alors l'autonomie
moyenne un jour et demi lorsque j'ai pas
mal joué lorsque j'ai été beaucoup sur
les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup à regarder du contenu vidéo ça
pas mal du multimédia un jour et demi ça
ça passe ça fonctionne
lorsque je suis plutôt à la cool je
bosse pas tout le temps sur mon
smartphone deux jours sans aucun
problème l'autonomie est vraiment
excellente sans l'iphone dit certes tout
ça c'est bien
c'est bien beau mais il y aussi pas mal
de points négatifs sur ce smartphone
maintenant on va regarder un petit peu
ce qui cloche
parce que même si ce smartphone est
extrêmement bien positionnée en termes
de prix pour un iphone il reste quand
même relativement cher on est à 855
euros
ça représente quand même une certaine
somme d'argent le fait de pas avoir
double objectif d'avoir juste un seul
objectif et papé l'objectif justement je
trouve ça un petit peu dommage cette
gamme de tarifs
du coup vous allez prendre des photos
vous aurez uniquement numériques palm
analogique
à ce prix là ça fait quand même là les
points négatifs là dessus par rapport à
d'autres iphone c'est que vous avez
uniquement trois éclairages de sel
vous n'avez pas plus mais là où ça fait
râler c'est que vous avez uniquement un
touche à petit que vous n'avez pas de 3d
dot et des fois ça marche des fois ça
marche pas c'est en tout cas parce qu
elle lieu si vous êtes vraiment habitué
autre auditeur là dessus vous risquez
vraiment de vous en mordre les doigts
autre point négatif sont les grosses
bordure sur le côté elles sont forcément
un peu plus grande que celle de l'iphone
10s c'est vrai qu'un smartphone à 855
euros avec séquences d'ordures
ça fait aussi râler
occupant qui fait râler c'est sur un
smartphone et 855 euros vous allez même
pas de résolution full hd
vous êtes en 1792 par huit 128 pixels
alors qu'on se verrait normalement un
minima en 1920 par 1080
voilà ça c'est aussi un point qui fait
franchement râler malgré ça est-ce qu'il
faut l'acheter j'aurais tendance à dire
ça dépend de vous tout simplement parce
que ça dépend de ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui comme smartphone ça dépend
de vos attentes ça dépend bien
évidemment de votre budget ça dépend pas
mal de facteurs on va essayer d grossir
un peu tout ça pour moi déjà du point de
vue de l'écran même si effectivement on
n'est pas sur du full hd je trouve qu'il
ya un vrai boulot qu'ils étaient faits
de la part d'apple là dessus vous avez
des écrans qui sont full hd et qui vont
être de moins bonne qualité que celui là
donc nahd su vous inquiétez pas ça vous
posera absolument aucun problème
j'ai regardé beaucoup de vidéos sur
netflix sur youtube
ça ne me pose pas de problème pour
regarder les photos c'est pareil ça pose
pas de problème néanmoins dans cette
bien de tarifs on trouvera toujours
moins cher sur un smartphone android
maintenant il faut éliminer petit peu
cette question comparatif avec android
parce que ce sera toujours un petit peu
pipés la donne il faut vraiment
réfléchir par rapport à ce que propose
apple la performance avec la puce à 12
bionique croyez moi j'ai fait plein de
jeux j'ai fait pas mal de choses avec
absolument aucune latence ça marche
extrêmement bien c'est hyper optimisée
du coup derrière vous avez aussi une
excellente autonomie
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne
parfaitement bien et là dessus vous
serez absolument pas déçu la photo la
photo c'est vraiment un point essentiel
aujourd'hui sur les smartphones
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
photophones et peut uniquement de
smartphones avec un appareil photo c'est
un bon photophone c'est pas un excellent
photophone si vous voulez vraiment un
excellent photophone allez plutôt faire
un tour du côté de chez huawei sur le
mail d'un gros scoop est un pro ou alors
même chez samsung sur le galaxy s 9 plus
ou sur le note 9
là vous allez vraiment d excellents
photophone celui ci fait vraiment bien
le job
le fait d'avoir la caméra 12 mégapixels
de couverture de f 1.8 en grand angle
derrière sa marche absolument bien on a
des photos bonne qualité et derrière
avec 1 h dr qui complètement optimiser
le rendu est vraiment bien donc pour
faire de la photo de bonne qualité vous
serez absolument pas déçu le fait de ne
pas avoir été l'objectif c'est pas
vraiment grave
le mode portrait fonctionne très très
bien d'un point de vue logiciel grâce
notamment à l'appui sa douce bio lit
derrière qui lui apporte vraiment une
capacité de calcul ça marche extrêmement
bien point un peu négatif
j'ai pas évoqué avant ses flèches
lorsque vous allez faire des photos
portraits préfère uniquement d'être
humain pouvait pas faire un portrait
avec un animal vu que c'est de
l'intelligence artificielle qui va
détecter un visage qui vont venir des
tours et vous pourrez pas nous faire
tous les modes portrait gle.fr qu'un
iphone 10 aces ou indice s max néanmoins
pour utilisation régulière à prendre des
clichés de très bonne qualité
ça fera parfaitement bien la ferme donc
l'écran marche bien la puissance est là
l'autonomie est là l'appareil photo est
là alors qu'est-ce qui va pas bah ce qui
est un peu moins bien et ce qui me fait
vraiment dire que ce smartphone est bien
mais c'est l'absence du 3d touch si vous
utilisez 3 nietzsche vous étiez vraiment
habitué aux 3 nov
ça va vous embêter à vous poser problème
parce que le touch haptique c'est pas
mal ça marche pas mal mais bon voilà
c'est pas complètement ça après 6,3
nettle je l'utilisé vraiment
occasionnellement n'aura absolument
aucun problème ça passera crème pareil
en termes de design le fait d'avoir ces
bords noirs sur le côté les oublie tout
de suite parce qu'on a un écran un peu
plus grand de 6,1 pouces donc ça ne pose
absolument aucun problème
alors maintenant la question est ce
qu'il faut l'acheter et si oui quoi
quand comment alors c'est là où ça
devient intéressant parce que si vous
avez un iphone 10 bien évidemment vous
n'avez pas changé
bien évidemment vous n'allez pas et sur
les flots 10r même si l'iphone 10r sera
plus performant et aura une meilleure
autonomie votre effectif
vous allez y perdre en terme de qualité
d'écran ça c'est quand même un peu con
surtout dans ses prix la même si
l'appareil photo principale de l'eifel
10r est meilleure par rapport à l'iphone
10 il n'y a pas non plus une valise et
car je conseille vraiment garder votre
iphone 10 alors maintenant si vous avez
un iphone qui plus anciens je pense
notamment à partir de l'iphone 7,7 plus
pour vraiment commencer à regarder pour
changer si par contre vous avez un
iphone 8 plus en termes de qualité de
photo c'est pareil a pas un écart énorme
non plus je suis pas sûr que ce soit
vraiment intéressant après ce qui vous
ferait change d'autres un iphone ou 8
plus il faut une 8 par rapport à un
iphone 10 r c'est vraiment le design le
fait d'avoir l'encoche le fait d'avoir
fait saïdi la caméra trop d'aix sinon je
suis pas sûr vous abonner conduite plus
pour moi conserver le il attendait la
génération suivante si maintenant vous
un iphone plus anciens ça vaut le coup
de changer parce que quand même une
vraie belle différence notable local
iphone 6,16 croyez moi que la différence
à est énorme
la qualité de l'écran tu en as
strictement pour rien à voir autant
aller tout de suite sans les fundis air
est alors si vous avez un smartphone
android pas quels qu'ils soient
si par exemple vous avez un 1008 garder
votre conduite il faut vraiment pas
l'intérêt d'aller là dessus même s'il
est quand même très très bon par contre
si vous avez un smartphone qui est un
peu anciens pour y aller il vous serez
absolument pas déçu à la question est-ce
que l'iphone 10r vaut le coup la réponse
est un grand oui c'est un excellent oui
c'est vraiment très très très grand oui
parce que je trouve qu'apple là dessus a
pas fait de compromis le fait du lcd
oled franchement pas bien grave
et surtout on a un vrai car de prix 300
euros de différence à kayes fundy 16 400
euros descacq l'iphone 10 s max
croyez-moi 300 euros c'est de l'argent
avec 300 euros vous allez pouvoir faire
pas mal de choses donc ça vaut vraiment
le coup de réfléchir et notamment avec
300 euros mais pouvoir vous offrir
plusieurs coques rhinochill histoire
vraiment le protéger et ça c'est
important parce qu'on n'en parlera
jamais assez
sortez protéger avec votre iphone ça
serait quand même dommage
il a beau être de bonne qualité si vous
le faites tomber vous allez le cas c'est
vous en ai franchement les boules dont
je vous invite à mettre une protection
d'écran comme salle de rhinau ch il est
derrière vous mettez une coque de
protection ou a minima
si vous voulez vraiment garder la
couleur de votre iphone vous mettez un
petit bum peur comme ça j'ai mon petit
bump heures salle protège j'ai mon
smartphone qui est protégé et ça c'est
plutôt coup d'ailleurs si ça vous
intéresse je vous ai mis des liens en
bas pour les découvrir cet iphone
glissait récit vous intéresse vous
pouvez passer par un bar pour les
prendre et vous avez également un code
promo chirino chine vous trouverez tout
ça en bas dans la description maintenant
à vous de me dire que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez psychology serre
par rapport à la concurrence comment
vous le trouvez par rapport à la f10 est
contré par rapport à l'iphone bis de
l'année dernière par rapport à l'iphone
8 plus est ce que vous trouvez qu apple
a vraiment fait un bon boulot là dessus
et est ce que vous êtes satisfait est ce
que vous l'avez acheté est ce que vous
êtes contente content oui non quoi
comment vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire merci en tout cas à vous
parce que là les scores et explose on
est bientôt à 85000 sur la chaîne c'est
juste dingue
hier une journée à plus de 500 nouveaux
abonnés c'est complètement hallucinant
donc merci à vous toujours plus
nombreuses toujours plus nombreux de
permettre que les choses évoluent et
d'ici quelques temps 10
qui allez on va dire quoi un mois et
demi on sera normalement cent mille 100
la chaîne c'était vraiment le challenge
que je m'étais lancé au début de l'année
on a commencé l'année on va être quoi
les 12000 15000 je sais plus je lis à la
fin de l'année faut qu'on soit à 100
milles et grâce à vous grâce à votre
soutien
on va y aller voilà c'est cool très
content merci à vous marquez bien sûr
tous voulant ben commentaire ce rendez
vous très bientôt
bisous
[Musique]
où